it is better to offer no excuse
than a bad one
we must consult our means
rather than our wishes
worry is the interest paid
by those who borrowed trouble
decision making
like coffee
needs a cooling process
if freedom of speech is taken away
then dumb and silent
we may be led
like sheep to the slaughter
a primary object
should be the education of our youth in
the science of government
let your heart feel for the afflictions
and distress of everyone
be not glad at the misfortune of another
though he may be your enemy
strive not with your superiors in
argument
but always submit your judgment to
others with modesty
real men despise battle
but will never run from it
individuals entering into society
must give up a share of liberty to
preserve the rest
99
of failures
are the ones who make excuses
a bad war is fought with a good mind
there is nothing so likely to produce
peace
as to be well prepared to meet the enemy
be courteous to all
but intimate with few
and let those few be well tried before
you give them your confidence
true friendship is a plant of slow
growth
and must undergo and withstand the
shocks of adversity
before it is entitled to appellation
it is better to be alone
than in bad company
human happiness and moral duty
are inseparably connected
to persevere in one's duty
and to be silent
is the best answer to colomney
there is nothing which can better
deserve our patronage than the promotion
of science and literature
knowledge is in every country the surest
basis of public happiness
to be prepared for war
is one of the most effectual means of
preserving peace
guard against the imposters of pretended
patriotism
labor to keep alive in your breast
that little spark of celestial fire
called conscience
perseverance and spirit
have done wonders in all ages
it is best to be silent
for there is nothing more certain than
that it is at all times
more easy to make enemies than friends
associate yourself with men of good
quality
if you esteem your own reputation
tis better to be alone than in bad
company
let us therefore animate and encourage
each other
and show the whole world that a free man
contending for liberty on his own ground
is superior to any slavish mercenary on
earth
a sensible woman
can never be happy with a fool
few men have the virtue to withstand the
highest bidder
happiness depends more upon the internal
frame of a person's own mind than on the
externals in the world
experience teaches us
that it is much easier to prevent an
enemy from posting themselves
than it is to dislodge them after they
have got possession
the heart of the conflict
the greater the triumph
the turning points of lives are not the
great moments
the real crises are often concealed in
occurrences so trivial in appearance
that they pass unobserved
as mankind becomes more liberal
they will be more apt to allow that all
those who conduct themselves as worthy
members of the community
are equally entitled to the protections
of civil government
to encourage literature and the arts
is a duty which every good citizen owes
to his country
a knowledge of books is the basis upon
which other knowledge is to be built
paper money has had the effect in your
state
that it will ever have
to ruin commerce
oppress the honest
and open the door to every species of
fraud and injustice
discipline is the soul of an army
it makes small numbers formidable
procures success to the weak
and esteem to all
those who have committed no faults want
no pardon
we are only defending what we deem our
indisputable rights
we should not look back unless it is to
derive useful lessons from past errors
and for the purpose of profiting by
daily bot experience
no punishment in my opinion
is too great
for the man who can build his greatness
upon his country's ruin
the common and continual mischiefs of
the spirit of party
are sufficient to make it the interest
and the duty of a wise people to
discourage and restrain it
the nation
which indulges towards another and
habitual hatred or and habitual fondness
is in some degree a slave
never attach
where it is obvious
the great rule of conduct for us
in regard to foreign nations is in
extending our commercial relations to
have with them as little political
connection as possible
government is not reason
[Music]
it is not eloquence
it is a force
and force like fire
is a dangerous servant and a fearful
master
in a good family
the husband is blind
and the wife is deaf
if to please the people
we offer what we ourselves disapprove of
how can we afterwards defend our work
let us raise a standard to which the
wise and honest can repair
the rest is in the hands of god
avoid a man who pretends to be your
friend
freedom and property rights are
inseparable
you can't have one without the other
nothing is more essential
than that permanent
inveterate antipathies against
particular nations
and passionate attachments for others
should be excluded
it is substantially true that virtue or
morality is a necessary spring of
popular government
the rule indeed
extends with more or less force to every
species of free government
religious controversies are always
productive of more acrimony and
irreconcilable hatreds than those which
spring from any other cause
you